Traduttore: Matteo Guareschi
Revisore: Silvia Fornasiero
Questo, al mio fianco, è un robot.
Io adesso mi avvicino
e con un semplice gesto,
gli faccio iniziare un suo programma
che eseguirà durante la mia presentazione.
Questo termine così evocativo, robot,
nasce nel 1920 dal dramma
del ceco Karel Kapek,
il dramma si chiamava Rur,
che significa Rossum Universal Robot.
In questo dramma
il dottor Rossum creava dei 'robota',
in ceco dei lavoratori,
in grado di lavorare al posto dell'uomo.
Questo al fine di liberare
l'umanità dalla schiavitù.
L'epilogo però fu tragico
e i robot presero
il sopravvento sull'umanità.
Io oggi sono qui
per illustrarvi uno scenario
decisamente migliore.
Perché l'uomo crea oggi i robot?
Li crea per fargli fare
quelle mansioni ripetitive
usuranti, pericolose,
che altrimenti farebbe l'uomo.
In questa foto vedete
un ambiente di lavoro ostile.
Questa è una forgia;
le persone sono a contatto
con il metallo liquido
estremamente pericoloso,
un'atmosfera a oltre 50 gradi.
Questo è un lavoro da robot.
E questa è una catena di montaggio.
Chi vuole ancora lavorare
in catena di montaggio
come faceva Charlie Chaplin
simpaticamente,
ripetendo la stessa operazione
per migliaia e migliaia di volte
durante la giornata?
Questa è un'attività
che devono fare i robot.
E apriamo tutto quel mondo
che è della robotica,
che lavora in ambito radioattivo,
ad esempio per lo smantellamento
delle centrali nucleari.
I robot vengono telecomandati
da remoto da delle persone
che altrimenti verrebbero
a contatto con la radioattività
e quindi contaminate.
Senza i robot non ci sarebbe
quell'incredibile esperienza
che è la chirurgia robotica
per la medicina moderna,
in cui i chirurghi sono in grado
di operare da New York a Milano
in telecontrollo del robot,
raggiungendo delle precisioni
dei decimi di millimetro e anche meglio,
altrimenti impossibili
con la mano dell'uomo.
In questa foto,
che probabilmente tutti conoscete
perché in molte pubblicità
i robot si vedono costruire
le moderne automobili
che oggi tutti guidate,
vedete tanti robot
tanti perché i robot devono
produrre molte automobili,
molti pezzi con la massima
qualità ottenibile.
Ma soprattutto non vedete
una cosa, in questa foto.
Non vedete degli uomini.
Questo perché questi sono
robot industriali, grandi, veloci,
che esercitano dei processi
come la saldatura
estremamente pericolosi per l'uomo.
I robot sono chiusi dentro delle gabbie;
ci sono delle barriere
tra l'uomo e il robot.
Ma le barriere esistono
per essere abbattute.
In questo video,
sia esso finzione o realtà,
vedete un robot industriale
che gioca a ping pong,
senza barriere, con l'uomo.
Questo perché alcuni anni fa
è nata una tecnologia
che chiamiamo robotica collaborativa.
I robot collaborativi,
come quello che è sul palco,
sono dei robot in grado
di coesistere nella stessa area
e collaborare con le persone
in maniera sicura.
Come lo fanno?
Grazie a una fitta rete di sensori
che gestiscono
l'interazione con l'esterno.
Questo robot sul palco
che sta lavorando mentre io parlo,
si chiama LBR;
in tedesco LBR significa "robot leggero"
ed è dotato di sette sensori di coppia,
quindi di elettronica, programmabile,
in corrispondenza
di ciascuno dei sette giunti.
Ma, soprattutto, è estremamente leggero
e quindi nel caso
di un urto con una persona,
non è traumatico, non fa male.
Quindi sarà possibile, in futuro,
avere un robot come collega?
Adesso io vi faccio vedere
un paio di video
di quello che è invece l'oggi,
di robot che lavorano
fianco a fianco con le persone.
In questo video vedete
un robot senza barriere
che aiuta l'operatrice
a muovere un oggetto
che è il differenziale di un'auto
che pesa più di 10 chili.
E soprattutto, vedete
che gestisce in sicurezza
una collisione come questa,
altrimenti molto rischiosa
per l'operatrice,
con un robot industriale tradizionale.
E guardate adesso cosa fa
un'altra operatrice:
ferma il robot con una mano
e lo fa riavviare,
come ho fatto prima io.
Questo in una linea di montaggio,
nella fattispecie di lavatrici,
ma quindi, i robot
effettivamente oggi collaborativi
sono all'interno delle aziende.
E la loro caratteristica
è che possono lavorare
fianco a fianco con le persone.
Ma cosa succederebbe se, ad esempio,
aprissimo casa nostra a un robot?
Un robot collaborativo, come questo,
che magari, nella fattispecie vedete
che ha due braccia,
ha una configurazione umanoide,
al mattino a colazione ci prepara
quello che mi sembra sia un pancake.
Diciamo che, per adesso,
a colazione continuo a fare da solo;
ma in industria, perché no?
E infatti, il mercato
dei robot collaborativi o Cobot,
che significa "Collaborative Robots",
sta crescendo in maniera incredibile:
tra cinque anni si venderanno nel mondo
lo stesso numero di robot
industriali e collaborativi,
cioè 500 mila e 500 mila
robot collaborativi.
Quali sono i motivi
di questa crescita pazzesca?
I driver sono due: uno di natura economica
e altri driver di natura
sociale e politica.
Le aziende vogliono sicurezza,
questo è importante,
vogliono lavorare senza barriere,
fianco a fianco coi robot
e questi robot fanno questo mestiere.
Le aziende vogliono
spendere poco in automazione
e questo è un fattore importante
che vedremo anche dopo,
meno rispetto
ai robot industriali tradizionali
e vogliono un robot semplice,
che si tocca con la mano
che si muove, che si programma.
Questo perché oggi produciamo oggetti
in dei lotti sempre più piccoli
e sempre più personalizzati,
quella che si chiama "mass customization".
Da un punto di vista sociale e politico,
questo dà la possibilità
del "back reshoring"
che significa riportarci le produzioni
in Paesi ad alto costo della manodopera,
come è ad esempio l'Italia,
al fine di contrastare
la competizione globale,
quindi di competere ancora
con questi Paesi,
e in mente ho
fondamentalmente il Far East.
Soprattutto da un punto di vista sociale,
far fare le cose
più semplici e ripetitive,
come dicevo prima, a questi robot.
Perché lo scopo dei robot non è
quello di mandare le persone a casa,
ma di mantenere l'occupazione
dedicandole ad altre attività,
a nuove mansioni che vedremo dopo.
Ma se apriamo tutto quel filone
che non è esattamente questo,
ma si chiama "robotica di servizio",
troviamo i robot nel settore didattico,
"educational" come questo,
che magari alcuni di voi conoscono;
robot assistivi, come questo esoscheletro
che aiuta le persone a camminare
o a fare riabilitazione;
dei "concept" veri e propri,
che a breve saranno industrializzati,
per avere un robot in cucina,
un po' più bravo di quello
che abbiamo visto nel video di prima.
Io sono convinto che molti di voi
hanno già un robot in casa.
Io ce l'ho. Aspira la polvere.
Si muove in un ambiente
di cui non ha la cartina.
Lo fa in maniera automatica e sicura.
Questo è un cobot.
Vi torna forse alla mente
questa provocazione di Bill Gates?
Tassare i robot, un anno
e mezzo fa circa, più o meno.
Bocciata dalla Comunità Europea
e, fondamentalmente, dalla comunità
robotica, ovviamente, e industriale.
Tassare più che altro la competitività,
anzi le aziende che hanno
una competitività aumentata
grazie all'utilizzo di automazione
flessibile e intelligente come questa.
Questo sarebbe solo
un freno all'innovazione
e genererebbe il fenomeno opposto
del back reshoring,
quindi il reshoring,
cioè le aziende vanno a produrre
dove si pagano meno tasse
e dove costa meno il lavoro.
D'altra parte, quando è uscito,
tanti anni fa oramai,
un pacchetto software che aveva
un foglio di calcolo
e un foglio di videoscrittura
nessuno ha proposto una tassa per questo,
nonostante diverse mansioni
chiaramente poi siano cambiate.
C'é un'analisi di McKinsey
molto interessante
che vi invito ad andare a vedere,
che la vede da un'ottica
completamente diversa e ottimistica.
McKinsey stima nel 2030,
700 milioni di persone
che verranno sostituite dai robot,
ma dedicate ad altre mansioni,
collaterali a quella dei robot.
Ovvero, la gestione dei "big data".
Questo robot fa un sacco di dati;
il mio cellulare fa un sacco di dati;
oggi siamo sui social,
tantissimi dati che vanno gestiti;
la gestione delle infrastrutture cloud
che li devono ospitare;
la creazione di applicazioni cloud-based,
finalizzate ad attività,
ad esempio, di robotica collaborativa;
e infine, l'intelligenza artificiale.
L'intelligenza artificiale è una cosa
che però già abbiamo sui nostri device.
Tutte queste tematiche sono racchiuse
su quella che si chiama
"quarta rivoluzione industriale",
che, per i robotici, e quindi per me,
in effetti è la seconda
rivoluzione robotica, quella dei "cobot",
perché la prima coincide
con la terza rivoluzione industriale,
che è la nascita del PLC
quindi di un sistema programmabile.
Cosa ci aspetta in un futuro prossimo
o abbastanza attuale?
La terza rivoluzione robotica,
quella della robotica mobile
in cui robot come questo stanno lavorando,
potranno lavorare
su dei sistemi mobili AGV
che si muovono nelle aziende
o anche nelle case, perché no?
E la quarta,
quella dell'intelligenza artificiale,
che per i robot significa:
non ci sarà più bisogno dell'uomo
per programmarli
perché loro grazie alle loro esperienze
e alle condizioni in contorno,
si programmeranno da soli.
Grazie.
(Applausi)